the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here where it's safe
we've all heard of the drama that went
on off screen during the making of
Olivia Wilde's film don't worry darling
but what really went on behind the
scenes to make this long-awaited movie
come to life here are all the behind the
scenes details we didn't know about
don't worry darling here we go number
one Harry Styles definitely knows how to
lighten the mood and isn't afraid to get
a little silly on set acting is serious
business no matter what film set you're
on and we all know that not everything
that went on behind the scenes with the
don't worry darling cast was all fun and
games it's clear by the looks of this
behind the scenes footage though that
hanging with Harry on set was anything
but serious sure this movie may have
sparked some drama among the cast what
do you think they're really doing out
there what do you mean but if these
clips are any indication we're sure that
having Harry as a co-worker almost
certainly lightened the tension number
two when don't worry darling's trailer
first dropped it took the Internet by
storm there are some iconic images from
the trailer that we all certainly
remember you probably recall this moment
that assures us that we're
unsurprisingly in for some incredible
acting from Florence Pew when we see
this movie it may not be our instinct to
wonder what goes on behind the scenes to
get a moment like this on film from this
clip though it's really incredible to
see the makings of an iconic on-screen
moment number three it's to be expected
that its leading lady would be involved
in at least a few action scenes but
judging by these clips from filming
Florence Pugh got more than her fair
share of exercise in while making this
film can you imagine doing all this
running take after take we suppose it's
all in a day's work for Florence number
four we're finally going to get a chance
to see hashtag Olivia hard at work let's
be real who Among Us doesn't want to
know a detail or two about how one of
Hollywood's it couples started out as a
workplace romance Legend has it that
Harry Styles and Olivia Wilde who are
known lovingly by fans as hashtag Olivia
began their love affair while working on
don't worry darling together while it's
safe to say that this onset clip is
probably just giving us a glimpse into
Olivia directing her movie's star rather
than an IRL lover's quarrel it's also
easy to see these two lovebirds
chemistry even when they're hard at work
number five driving on camera is
actually a lot harder than it is IRL we
don't tend to think about how exactly
driving scenes and movies are made but
according to this clip of cameras
filming Florence Pugh driving in what
appears to be a car chasing there's a
lot that goes into it still it's
probably not nearly as much as what went
into this intense car crash scene
hopefully no cars were harmed in the
making of this moment but we find that
hard believe number six it's clear that
Harry and Florence are the perfect Jack
and Alice it's got to be pretty weird
making out with someone you're not
actually dating with cameramen and a
boom operator just a few feet away from
you still as two of today's most beloved
Stars Florence Pew and Harry Styles are
professionals and they seem to be
totally used to it by now I like about
acting as I feel like I have no idea
what I'm doing besides the general
awkwardness of being movie stars these
clips also show that Harry and Florence
have plenty of chemistry to make their
characters Jack and Alice come to life
number seven we know you want to know
all about what's going on behind the
scenes during that dinner party scene as
is very fitting for a movie about gender
Dynamics inspired by the 1950s don't
worry darling has a very pivotal scene
that's set during a dinner party Olivia
Wilde said that it was intimidating
creating such a pivotal scene in a
setting that may have lost the
audience's attention she said she
ensured that the audience would stay
engaged in the scene by adding a score
that would make it feel like a battle
scene and so you have to continue to
inject energy into the scene as well as
incredible camera work this behind the
scenes footage of the scene being filmed
proves just how vital this camera work
is likely to be to the end product
number eight according to Olivia there
were plenty of accidents that happened
throughout the making of the movie that
ended up making it even better she says
that even an unexpected onset explosion
made the movie better if that's true she
either looks at the glass very half full
or has some serious luck number nine
Harry gets back to his musical roots and
don't worry darling while Harry Styles
is certainly a serious player in the
acting game nowadays we all know that
music is his first love when you see him
performing on stage uncomfortable is not
a word you'd use to describe him yet
acting is a bit of a different story in
his own words acting is kind of very
uncomfortable at times I think you have
to trust a lot it requires hires a lot
of trust if you want to give it
everything so not everything about being
in front of the camera makes Harry
totally at ease but by the looks of this
behind the scenes footage we can see
that when he combines acting with his
knack for performing on stage he's
definitely in his sweet spot number 10
lots of 1950s inspiration went into
making the film what it is according to
Olivia Wilde this was certainly Central
to the movie's plot so inspired by the
architecture art film and music of that
era she even made mood boards featuring
lots of famous faces from that era like
Nat King Cole and Frank Sinatra and she
modeled Florence Pugh's look after
Bridget Bardo number 11 so much
attention to detail was paid when
creating the fictional setting Victory
and making it the perfect imperfect
Utopia but according to both Harry
Styles and Chris Pine the set made
acting easy and allowed them to fall
into the rhythm of people living during
that time period number 12. Olivia's
original idea for victory was based
based on a photo called poolside gossip
by a series of fortunate events they
ended up shooting the first scene at the
exact location where the photo was taken
it's amazing how things work out when
you have an absolutely massive movie
budget number 13 plenty of directors act
in their own movies and it's pretty hard
to imagine doing two jobs at once like
that and don't worry darling Olivia
Wilde seems to pull off these double
rolls well but this behind the scenes
clip shows just how many hats she had to
wear during some scenes and highlights
just how much of a challenge that must
have been number 14 it's called movie
Magic for a reason and seeing this BTS
clip shows us just how many people and
how many little details go into making
sure major film shoots go off without a
hitch seeing the crew setting up markers
for the actors is a good reminder that a
lot more goes into making movies than
meets the eye when we're watching it on
screen number 15 as it turns out
Olivia's ability to act while directing
was a big reason why Florence he was in
the movie at all Olivia Wilde actually
originally cast herself as the lead role
but being a leading lady while directing
is definitely not as easy as it sounds
and the costumes involved with the
period piece were certainly no help
according to Olivia all of these men had
done this in comfortable shoes and I
swear part of it is that I was in a
[ __ ] bustier in heels and a wig
ultimately Olivia was tired of getting
touch-ups to her hair and makeup and
says she thought I need to be at the
monitor I need to be in charge and so
Olivia did decide to focus on her
directing gig more and she thought
casting a younger actor as Alice would
fit the story better anyway plus casting
Florence Pew is always the right mood
what do you think of what went on behind
the scenes during the making of don't
worry darling are you excited to see the
movie we want to hear all about it in
the comments and if you liked this video
remember to like And subscribe to the
things for all the best entertainment
news